alexis poulain bonjour alors est ce que
l'on peut dire que le secteur de la
culture est sacrifiée oui pour certains
c'est clair voir la façon dont ont été
qualifiés de non essentielle les
activités culturelles et choquant pour
de nombreux acteurs de ce secteur
culturel qui ne comprennent pas en fait
la stratégie du gouvernement de reculer
on peut ranger janvier l'ouverture des
théâtres des musées des cinémas sachant
que aujourd'hui on peut aller à dans les
lieux de consommation dans les lieux de
culte mais pas papa dans les lieux de
culture où on se retrouve et qui sont
importants pour la vie en société
extrêmement important et puis c'est un
secteur qui pèse lourd particulièrement
en france 1 on est à 2 3% du pib 80
milieu humain qui accueillent du public
et plus de 670 mille emplois qui sont
menacés
trois quarts ont plus intermittent la
moitié des emplois permanents et un
secteur privé de la culture qui va
énormément souffrir parce que non
subventionnées ou peu subventionné et ce
manque à gagner sur cette année va être
extrêmement difficile donc c'est
compliqué pour les acteurs culturels de
se voir marquer non essentiels alors que
les imaginaires sont essentiels à la
construction politique à la construction
à léquilibre même et puis se retrouver
aussi pour échapper au réel cette
période de virus compliqué difficile
tout ça est interdite faute de virus
donc emmanuel macron parlait de
chevaucher le tigre lorsqu'il avait fait
cette conférence de presse surréaliste
cet été pour les acteurs du secteur
culturel on a l'impression que c'est le
tigre qui va finir par les manger alors
alexis est ce que c'est une opportunité
pour les gars femmes
et oui une de plus on a déjà vu la façon
dont amazon géant américain profiter de
cette crise dont les profits sans vol
parce que les gens commandent davantage
parce qu'il ya ce plan porté par davos 1
par klaus web du great myths and qui
voudrait que l'économie numérique
prennent le dessus soit stimulée par ce
virus et que finalement les liens qui
nous unissent tout ce qui est matériel
disparaissent et donc certains acteurs
de la culture dont mathieu kassovitz
sont prêts à dire que les salles de
cinéma bien c'est fini c'est le monde
d'hier et que tout ça va évoluer que
maintenant on consomme du cinéma
autrement voyez ce mot consommer mais
derrière il ya de la création derrière
il ya tout un équilibre économique
extrêmement précaire sur la création
nationale française qui n'en sais pas
l'achat de billets pour aller au cinéma
sur la création du spectacle vivant
salez les plateformes ne vont pas
pouvoir capter cette créativité se lit
bien entre public et acteurs qui sont
sur scène et c'est terrible de voir que
finalement on voudrait et c'était aussi
ce que proposait mâcon réinventer le
rapport au public les attentes et la
façon dont on va trouver du public
trouver les moyens de jouer en passant
par le numérique toujours plus de
numérique toujours plus de
dématérialisation et une fois encore ce
sont les plateformes américaines qui
sont les mieux placés pour produire des
séries pour produire et pour une fois
encore et produire de l'imaginaire et
donc attaquer les imaginaires là où
l'exception culturelle française avait
été la loi pendant des années on avait
su protéger une création nationale est
quelque chose d'extrêmement difficile
que ce que les géants d'hollywood ont
beaucoup plus de moyens et cette crise
malgré les 2 milliards du plan de
relance culture où il ya tout dedans à
la fois le patrimoine la formation la
commande publique ne va peut-être pas
permettre de sauver la création
française et ça c'est extrêmement grave
merci beaucoup alexis poulain alexis
ponnet rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialistes et